[Music]
[Applause]
let me
explain myself and i would tell
[Applause]
[Music]
as much as you are
every resident of the metropolitan zoo
has died and now for the weather
jim thanks jim as you can see behind me
it's
3 37 in the afternoon
[Music]
dry
jim i'm dr e plier
i'm sorry you're dying
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
think she cares nope bad dog
littering is awesome bad dogs
[Music]
that you fear
mountains the secret killer and now for
the weather
jim jim i'm currently in the center of
the sun
uh it's hot that i can tell you
still dry jim
are life's crushing responsibilities
keeping you
glum well look no further than bubbles
that's right bubbles can solve all of
life's problems
parents divorcing crippling depression
the bubbles did your wife leave you
balls
realizing that maybe bubbles aren't the
solution to all of your problems
[Music]
[Laughter]
order your bubbles today call bubbles
that's 1-888
bubbles
you loved hearing mark's delightful
mouth sounds in
markiplier warms up for five minutes
introducing mark bob you can hear mark
using his undeniable talent to recreate
your favorite songs
from the 90s right into your ears
bringing you
[Music]
um
and who could
oh hi i'm sorry you're dying
oh no what and
welcome back to disc of riches
whoa welcome back to the final round
everybody we've made it here after a
long time everybody else was
dead and gone but you guys have survived
we got
blue boy instead please with 4 321
we got lady denim over there with 6823
oh and bringing up the big godzilla's
the big man
in the stupid vest it's mr 10 228.
oh good for you good for you i don't
even care about your names but i know
that you're in first place
which means that you get to have a
chance
to solve this puzzle unless you want to
try to
get another letter in there ah
i think i'm gonna i think i'm gonna go
ahead and solve this oh look at the
cojones on this boy here
all right do it do it
come on kill me i'm here come on do it
now kill me
all right so i mean
what's he going what's going on why he
asked me to do it
you can't keep doing this what are you
talking about he asked me to do
it that was the game you can't get
killing content he
said kill me kill me now
honey i'm home
i'm sorry no you're dying
and all of the badgers thankfully died
and now for the weather
jim thanks jim seems like santa claus
might not be coming to town this year as
you can see all of his reindeer have
burst into flames uh due to global
warming uh who'da thought al gore
was right that son of a [ __ ] so
pitchforks at the ready let's go to his
house jim
are you constantly haunted by the ghosts
of everyone that you killed and maybe
you think that it was you that was the
problem and it wasn't just a
misunderstanding where you were trying
to tickle them with a knife
help me a woman
so what do you think
is [ __ ]
or taking enough of you guys
look this is an opportunity that
can't be missed it's for everybody not
you
and it's gonna leap the nation so
listen to old morphy cause uh wilford
knows
what's best
i appreciate what you've done for us
[Music]
if we're to get back on track we need to
refine our goals and unify
into a singular strategy well i think
we're missing the bigger picture here
i was promised a 30-second spot now
where was it i got barely
five there and i know how to count to
five i know how to count to a good deal
if you know what i'm talking about
yeah no all right
look i think everyone's overlooking the
most important detail here
i was supposed to be the host of that
game show segment
i mean i'm bim trimmer i know i took a
break from fighting crime for a while to
pursue
a job in entertainment but this isn't
what i had in mind
considering i actually wasn't in that
what are you talking about
this is revolutionary it's gonna change
everything we know about television
trust you me
listen guys i'm a doctor uh i know
what's best and
it wasn't actually that bad it featured
my ideas quite well and i came across as
a very professional and handsome actor
so i said we keep it the camera shifts
over to the host who continues to talk
about the situation and then it pans
over to the next person
i know this is off topic but i still
need to sell my son i'm willing to go
for
10 off of the whole price go back all
the way to 10
take 90 off actually if you could just
use the opinion
i uh i'm king of the squirrels
i respect you i always have
but you're missing the point of this
endeavor
all right all right okay
[Music]
uh what do you think septiplier kill me
kill me
all right whatever you say you little
scamp